mon soir à tous alors là soleil va se
suffit est il vraiment possible et si
facile de s'opposer à la face leipp opté
pour un itinéraire bis et switcher vers
la slow life
il ya maintenant cinq ans j'ai fait un
switch de responsable juridique à
professeur de yoga et comme l'avait très
justement dit mon conseiller pôle emploi
de l'époque je faisais le grand écart
sans aucun genou bien sûr pour vous
refaire l'histoire avec moi avec le yoga
elle est finalement arrivé par hasard je
voulais changer un peu ma routine
sportive j'ai voulu tester un cours dans
la salle de sport dans laquelle j'étais
abonné donc j'étais c est ça a été une
révélation
dès le premier cours j'ai senti les
bénéfices c'était la première fois que
je dormais si bien depuis des mois je me
suis mise donc à pratiquer un peu plus
de plus en plus à commencer par un de
cours par semaine pour un pour en venir
après à tous les jours il a certaines
études qui démontrent que le yoga est
une drogue plus forte que le café et je
dois admettre que je vais lui totalement
cette théorie car été littéralement
addict plus je pratiquais plus je me
sentais on va dire différentes
j'étais apaisé moi qui suis de nature
hyperactive nerveuse impulsive
tout d'un coup je me sentais plus
légères apaisée plus calme
je commençais à comprendre que
l'essentiel dans la vie c'était prendre
soin de soi et des autres
je me suis mise donc la pratique est de
plus en plus et je sentais une certaine
reconnexion à mon corps je commençais à
prendre conscience de mon alimentation
de ma relation avec les autres et
surtout le yoga a commencé à mettre avec
de l'or dans la tête a mis en lumière
certaines choses et m'a fait prendre
conscience que je n'étais pas heureuse
dans mon travail et que je n'étais pas
épanouie du coup j'ai fini
moment je me suis pas trop posé de
questions j'ai continué à faire du yoga
à pratiquer jusqu'au jour où en fait
c'est apparu comme une évidence
il fallait que je quitte mon travail car
quelque chose d'autre m'attendais le
switch a été finalement assez rapide
après seulement quelques mois de
pratique je décide de quitter mon
travail pour me consacrer à cette
passion qu'est le yoga je commence donc
à avoir une nouvelle vision de la vie
dans laquelle il est important de se
faire du bien de prendre soin des autres
et c'est à ce moment là vraiment que je
commence à entrer dans le slot livre
récent la le mans
le problème qui se pose c'est comment
assumer cette ligne r 10 là ce qui est
là selon l'âge
alors évidemment vis-à-vis des autres
c'est pas évident il ya la pression
sociale elle est bien là alors du coup
comment assumer vis-à-vis des autres
forcément c'est très différente du mode
de vie des autres alors évidemment j'ai
le soutien de certaines personnes qui
m'ont soutenu dans mes démarches
en revanche il ya deux personnes qui ont
essayé de me décourager qui m'ont dit
que je faisais une grosse connerie que
c'était que c'était n'importe quoi
finalement de quitter son job de
responsable juridique et est si
confortable que c'était du gâchis
d'avoir fait un magistère des vicieux
pour ensuite tout simplement arrêter le
droit que c'était si rare d'être membre
du comité de direction d'une boîte à
l'âge de 27 ans donc voilà donc au final
je peux écouter les réponses du compte
j'ai continué à croire en fait on se
rend ce mode de vie j'ai donc opté pour
laszlo divine et c'est vrai que ça n'a
pas été facile parce que il faut
reconnaître que nous vivons dans une
société où la société a constamment le
pied sur l'accès sous l'accélérateur la
société du face les villes société du
ghisi tirer naissent plus on et bizi
mieux c'est il faut le reconnaître il
est classiquement plus accepter de
d'être tout le temps occupé car plus tu
es busy pluie tuerie ici dans la vie
non il faut le remarquer qu'on est dans
cette société de fass libye où tout va
encore toujours plus vite tous fini tout
est dans tout et finalement millions
tout est encore plus rapide à cause des
nouvelles technologies et des réseaux
sociaux
alors du coup face à ça le problème
c'est comment ralentir
à
cette société de fass living j'ai voulu
prendre un contre-courant j'ai voulu
justement prendre le temps de vivre
pensez à moi réajuster le conte le le
rythme donc qu'est-ce que le seul
olivier alors fait cette société qui en
constante accélération il est important
de ralentir le rythme alors ralentir le
rythme s'est pas forcément faire les
choses lentement mais c'est bien
fonctionner autrement
pour ce faire il faut adopter de
nouveaux gestes
il faut bloquer des moments de détente
dans son emploi du temps
réapprendre à vivre alors je vous cache
pas que pour la personne
hyperactif que je suis ça n'a pas été
facile de ralentir j'ai dû justement
prendre conscience de beaucoup de choses
prendre conscience de mes mauvaises
habitudes adopter de nouveaux gestes
comme pratiquer le yoga quotidiennement
même si c'est que cinq minutes
pratiquer la méditation passer du temps
dans la nature
cuisiner au lieu d'arrêter de commander
des plats cuisinés sur des applis de
livraison chose qu'on fait beaucoup
maintenant écouter un podcast infir en
lire des livres
tous ces moments de détente qui nous
procure un bien fou et qui au final sont
sont pas assez pratiqué
et la question
on peut se poser c'est alors pourquoi en
fait on n'ose pas vraiment faire toutes
ces choses là est la question qui
revient c'est simplement partie
culpabilité on se prive de ces moments
là parce qu'on a un autre souci trop
souvent l'inactivité
à la lenteur et à la paresse alors il
faut se détacher du sentiment de
culpabilité qui souvent attachés à
l'inactivité l'inactivité ne veut pas
dire paraissent la lenteur ne veut pas
dire paraissent avec le sol y vient j'ai
appris à apprécier ces petits riens qui
était alors jusqu alors imperceptible
j'ai découvert la gratitude
lorsque l'on a besoin de rien lorsque
nous avons tant de prendre notre temps
nous devenons simplement reconnaissant
d'être heureux
alors forcément
vous allez me dire oui mais c'est un peu
facile
beau mais concrètement comment faire
alors pour ralentir il faut fuir le
stress
il faut prendre le temps de vivre lâcher
prise vivre intensément le moment
présent et à tous ceux qui pensent que
finalement je ne serais pas en train de
que je veux que je risquais de me perdre
dans cette démarche volontaire de
simplicité
je leur partageraient cette citation de
franck michel voyage au bout de la route
avec la vitesse
nous savons peut-être tout ce que nous
avons gagné en temps et en argent sur
tout mais nous ne savons pas encore tout
ce que nous avons perdu
ainsi donc en fait ce que je cherche à
vous expliquer ces
on oublie trop souvent en fait à
surcharger nos journées à se bloquer
trop d'activités
on passe à côté de l'essentiel on oublie
les valeurs simples fondamentale sur le
plan existentiel
c'est pourquoi il faut un vrai retour
aux valeurs
un vrai retour aux choses simples
prendre le temps de vivre devrait
ralentir pour mieux vivre
ce que je ne cache pas et que mal même
si on essaie de ralentir
on est toujours rattrapé par la
technologie et perd cette société de
fass living
les filles
par exemple
je dois vous avouer que j'ai pas mal de
mal à me détacher de mon smartphone car
je suis quelqu'un d'hyper connectés je
suis très connectés aux réseaux sociaux
instagram en particulier est alors le
problème c'est j'utilise en fait la
technologie et les réseaux sociaux
en plus la technologie on va dire pour
ralentir par exemple j'utilise des
applications pour méditer j'utilise des
applications pour traquer mon sommeil
pour veiller à ce que je dorme assez
parce que le sommeil est importante il
ne faut pas l'oublier également
j'utilise instagram comme toute
communication est ce que j'essaie de
mettre en évidence et qui a comme un
véritable paradoxe parce qu on utilise
la technologie pour alan pire parce que
nous avons même en plein d'applications
qui nous permettent cela qui nous
permettent d'enclencher en fait ce
nouveau mode de vie de laszlo living le
solage pardon
et au final on est toujours rattrapé par
celle ci qui n'a pas remarqué récemment
les notifications que l'on reçoit sur
notre smartphone pour nous indiquer le
temps de le temps que l'on a passé sur
les écrans c'est finalement complètement
paradoxal parce que moi par exemple je
les consulte ce cas elle apparaît sans
que je le désire en fait
et alors et en fait ça me stresse
puisque de choses parce que je me dis
mes mains je passe beaucoup trop de
temps sur les écrans ça va pas du tout
donc au final ce que je sais vous
expliquer c'est que même si on essaie de
ralentir la technologie est toujours là
et quelque part elle dit poursuit
ici le concept de slow laisse me parle
autant finalement ce n'est pas seulement
parce que c'est inhérent au yoga et aux
modes de vie associés mais c'est parce
que aussi je le vois vraiment comme un
correcteur de de ma personnalité
hyperactive et également un correct et
une réponse à mon hyper connexion
dans un monde en quête de sens je pense
qu'il est important de revenir à
l'essentiel de ce qui nous rend vraiment
heureux et serein
et tous les jours posez vous cette
question est ce que j'ai pris le temps
pour moi aujourd'hui
et pour que
talk je vais vous proposer un exercice
très simple que vous pouvez faire tous
les jours plusieurs fois par jour pour
revenir au calme ralentir le rythme
prendre soin de vous vous reconnecter à
vous-même donc vous aller tranquillement
vous allez d'étendre les bras les placer
sur les genoux vous allez fermer les
yeux
relâché les épaules relâchées
tranquillement vous allez c'est de vous
reconnecter à vous même de vous
reconnecter à la respiration qui
tranquillement vous allez levez les bras
vers le plafond
vous allez ramener les membres hier
devant la poitrine devant le centre du
coeur et vous allez juste prendre
quelques intants instants pour sentir
les battements de votre coeur
voyez si vous pouvez sentir les
battements de votre coeur
et on va prendre 103 respiration
[Musique]
vous allez inspirer par le nez
expirez par la bouche
[Musique]
encore deux fois inspiré
et ce piège
une dernière fois une grande inspiration
indra expiration
que tranquillement qui vont mourir vos
yeux et aurait lâché tranquillement
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]